hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany to
show where we do just that and my guest
today is an art historian curator and
manager Marlon a command is her name and
here she is in person thank you very
very much for joining us here today on
talking Germany it's great pleasure and
a privilege now Mario Ackerman is a
hugely info influential figure in the
world of art here in Germany not least
because she runs what is viewed as one
of the country's best art museums that
is the Const Sam long
nordrhein-westfalen or in English the
art collection of the german federal
state of north rhine-westphalia which is
to be found in the Rhineland city of
Dusseldorf in Germany's north west
mariana command first question your
museum has been described as Germany's
and I'm quoting here secret National
Gallery is it that good yes I to say it
has one of the most beautiful
collections worldwide but it's just not
a huge collection so our founding
director vanish man back always said
it's quality not quantity and and so you
must imagine him he started in the year
61 to acquire works from the state of
North rhine-westphalia and he had in the
first two years 20 million deutsche mark
and in these times or 61 62 and a lot of
money better though there was a lot of
money so it was the biggest budget
inside Germany in these times and but
then he waited four years to find the
best Picasso to define the best
Kandinsky and so we have an excellent
paris-based and collection of European
modernism and was released main works of
the artist or very unusual works of them
you can see in and when there's no other
museum with such so like Marie Yanni we
have portraits of modigliani and they
are so special so he had really a very
good view on the art and then he
collected very early American modernism
you must say too in a way of many years
before more masada to collect and he
always said in
out of the pot to casa so it means so a
little money so it was very achieved in
these times because it was fresh so he
acquired Pollock the most famous product
of the world Jackson Pollock yeah for
very little money and and so yeah with
these density of quality reacts
exceptional okay I've got the message
you've got a very very high-quality
collection as anybody who has been to
your Museum well no I've just got one
thing you talk there about the moma yeah
yeah that's it that that in the modern
world it's very very important that
museums are branded that it's very easy
to talk about them when you talk about
the Mona that the moma that's iconic
yeah yeah your Museum and I'm going to
repeat what I said earlier is the [ __ ]
Sam lenoir-rhyne best violin or the art
collection of the German state of North
rhine-westphalia it's not as some
journalists say sexy yeah that's right
and so we there was the tried to use the
names K 20 K 21 and and we use it widely
in the world but the problem is that and
when you want to have some famous art
words from other collections they know
this difficult word quincel North not
even if you can't spell it in English
yeah and I don't know why but then they
trust us so it's something like I don't
know so it's really difficult to read
use the different names we have to one
brand but we I would confess we still
have to work on it okie dokie stuff so
maybe a little bit of rebranding is
necessary tell me about you as a museum
director as a museum manager what makes
you different from other museum
directors in a nutshell and i am still
i'm a widely supported by the state or
county of nationalist failure so i can
acquire I can feel like wire so I
perhaps we are the last the last museum
in Germany or what has really can work
on the collection and so you can go out
and buy yeah no I'm totally independent
so we r foundation but we have full
support by the state so this is a great
mixture of so a balance with we have you
are free you can nobody is
talking you in and trying to influence
you well well well well well talk about
that in just a second bell sounds like I
mean I said it they at the beginning
you're very influential and very
powerful you certainly are from what you
tell him we've got to talk about that in
detail in just a second let's talk about
you when you were a very very young girl
that was this one if there's one fact
that i read that was that was very
interesting you grew up in a family like
mine i have to say they didn't have a TV
at home yes that's true in a way it's a
disadvantage because and i would say
self film and video and moving image is
so important for our time in from the
20th century but yeah it was like that
let's just go we've got a couple of
photos of you from from from those days
back then when the one you were i don't
know let so let's have a look let's see
the photos um there we go yeah what can
you remember there how old were you
there i think four or so full i mean it
was an uncle huh and I'm stairs was in
anger because you lived in Turkey yeah
yeah I left and I when we when I've been
two years old we moved to turkey from
7-8 years then and yeah and I grew up
there there's this fascinating detail
there are there's another one that what
are we seeing now that's Turkey to I
would guess yes it's okie and you can
see that we have these special shoes as
children because it was very hot in
summer though its continental climate
yeah but because of the snakes so my
mother was a sneaks yeah my mother was
so anxious that we have kids you
mentioned your mother there there's this
story that your mother was a very
pragmatic woman she was teaching at the
University and she would take you along
and leave you at the back of the class
and gents a right you're doing ah yeah
so in a way so my mother was really
highly talented author who was painting
and drawing every day and so it was so
difficult in Germany in this in these
years 24 especially for women too she
wanted to go her way and so my parents
left Germany to be more free really yes
and so shouldn't
DRDs of German academic exchange program
they could both teach at the University
in Ankara hmm and from a mother it was
possible to combine it with family so
she was working full time every day and
she was taking us always every day with
her and so we grew up in a very relaxed
way because in Turkey the people have
been very open some also to kids of
course but I'm and so I think these
friendliness of the Turkish people I
will have forever in my memory wonderful
wonderful I'm a big fan of turkey and
Turkish people as well I must say I
share that with you and this this
experience of being with your mother of
being of being set the task of doing
drawings and paintings did that have an
impact on is that where it all began
with you being the person you are going
into the world of art studying in this
direction it was both it was really
seeing my mother living for the art and
but really the other thing was perhaps
her her story so she as she came from a
quiet rich family and Angie lived in
cleaver and flavor was bombed out during
the Second World War and so the family
of my mother they lost their house and
the villa villa and all the material
things they left all things and after
the war she was 15 45 and she was living
for the eris and for the spiritual
things and he always told me only the
immature is important that's very
interesting you're talking about how
your mother responded to our door her
relationship to our which is something
you learned from that yeah we're going
to talk about you going out and
acquiring it a purchasing art maybe just
tell me this when you when you are in a
room with an artwork br2 painting on the
wall or whatever it is yeah do you
respond when you're enthusiastic do you
respond physically or do you respond
intellectually physically first I will
describe that and you in a way you are
excited so physically excited so and it
doesn't happen too often hmm that's good
for her people and you really feel your
way too much time
or in trapping every day yeah yeah and
but very often it is also followed by a
doubt so the first reaction is very
intense and then the intellect is
starting to work and you're thinking
about her thinking and very often than
you have doubts because normally you
have this reaction when you have seen
something new what you didn't know
before yeah and so then it comes like
the questions are coming is it really
good and what how can I explain it and
and so this is a quite long process and
so when you never forget it so when
you're thinking for 34 years about it
and you can't get it out of your mind
yeah then nothing you have something you
know that that there must be something
which is what's very interesting and
yeah I'd like to follow up on that the
whole sort of the way you respond to our
because you said something which I
thought was interesting you said making
art is about you said making history
perceptible in exhibitions okay so far
so good you also said it's about
highlighting the questions being posed
in the present and what are the
questions being posed in the present
that's difficult aren't in one sentence
on time able to it means um for example
when you when you're working with
artists everybody knew Kandinsky or
Malevich or Alexander corner or so it so
the stars the heroes of the modernism
your heroes my heroes can say and and
you ask yourself what is when a person
of 18 years or 20 years coming to the
museum what could be interesting for
this person exactly and and it can be
something which is very political a real
question which is very important
concerning society and politics but it
could also be in a question concerning
more aesthetic aspects like Alexander
Korda was so much influenced by in
experimental music and this was really
radical in these times in the 20's and
30's which you did and it is not known
and so we we try to realize a called
exhibition which you can see at the
moment is it up and and you can
you can hear the sculptures are
producing sound and it's very radical
and I see that the young audience is so
much interested in it can be another
project Kandinsky Malevich Mondrian
there have been so many exhibitions
about these heroes of modernism but
nobody asked ever what white means there
are more than thousand pigments so we we
are questioning what is white paint and
that is interest and the German language
doesn't have words for it so in some
northern languages yet small books and
and and my cell my fees so i can say i'm
telling the audience when you when you
can't see the difference between the
subtle shades of white you are not we
have no chance to see the universe so
the annuity but I means and determined
to make them more sensible for things of
our actual world this is my aim
fascinating what a mission what a
mission to have in life making people
more sensitive for subtle shades of
white if fascinating stuff now we're
going to talk in just a minute about an
exhibition an installation that is that
has been causing a bit of a sensation
and a lot of excitement at mariana
commands dusseldorf museum
and the name of that is as we've seen in
orbit yeah you have to put a white suit
on have you have you had one of the
white suits on a presume you have yes it
is a question of security that nothing
can fell down I see and how does it feel
to be up there when you were have you
been there more than once I mean you
must have spent more than this sort of
their the normal 10 minutes up there ya
know what is very interesting for me it
depends on your daily condition oh so it
makes you more it your it's the in
stable situation and it depends of watch
how you on the day so it's every day
it's different and this is what Thomas
casino once he wants really to to change
the people he wants to bring them into
another Colorado we have a photo yeah
yes it's nice that I was on it I did
believe you that I did believe you yeah
I know what a lot of people will be
thinking that question that you hear so
often to you probably hear so often is
it art yeah of course we had a public
discussion on this leg rub playground or
utopian examines diagram and but so here
you have to do to deeply dive into the
thinking of Tomas a casino in his head
his whole work though and you really
understand that he's one of these
artists of the younger generation who is
again speaking about utopian ideas that
for me it's very fascinating to see that
since two or three years they're talking
about future is coming back again and
and so the title the first title was a
citation from malevich from its
manifesto for suprematism and the
russian artist kazimir malevich lesson
in this down yeah yeah so um something
to have something like a utopian idea
that you are leaving the earth and going
to the universe and and and thomas he
and he also wants to have these social
experience when you are going into the
installation you feel the movements of
the other people and so you feel you
only come to a higher level when you're
doing something together you feel the
vibration and so and and and then the
spiders are very
version as a model and they are social
spy types of spiders and and semi social
types and then producing different forms
of of webs and nets and this is the
frame I'm like a visual model for the
artwork you've got me wondering whether
I'm a social spider or a semi socialist
I don't know what the answer to that
would be you have told me you have a
budget yeah and you could in theory go
out and buy a power play or a Kandinsky
have I understand on paper yeah that's
the pebble missing it because the art
market is out of control at the moment
and that you've got a relatively fixed
budget it might be a generous budget
yeah what can you do with it it's
impossible now to continue to collect so
these expensive worked of modernism what
you could do you could collect female
artists oh but when you take the famous
female artist polymer doesn't Becca
German artist very brilliant artist in
this case the best works are already in
public collections so you have no chance
so you can still acquire American
modernism so I just quit a quiet Agnes
Martin and it kind heart and but the
better thing is how much how much did
you spend can you reveal this to us some
millions okay in every case yeah but
it's it's much better also to to think
about contemporary art and and perhaps
artworks who are not so much influenced
by the market they are still brilliant
artists which still exist still exists
which future can find in the market hmm
not producing works for the market and I
think it's important for the public
museums to concentrate on these artists
who I am now the art world Germany
Jewish communities worldwide and many
other observers and commentators all
have been rocked recently by the
discovery of a huge trove of artworks in
a Munich apartment many of the pieces
went missing during the nancy period now
if they will put on display together the
paintings and other works would
certainly be an eye-catching exhibition
the question is though
who do they belong to
our own a command there are so many
different ways we could talk about this
story I'd like to try three different
levels first level is just what's your
response to the find of the century this
bizarre story totally unexpected yeah
it's a sensation we are all just cussing
it since two weeks it's for me it's very
sad that there was a lie that the whole
collection was burned during the bombing
of twisting and everybody believed it
because you noticed this was the story
that the father yeah the final it senior
put out all the all the paintings were
destroyed in the dresden fire yeah and
so you can fear that there perhaps other
lies of other stories be cont because
you can track you can't prove it in the
moment and now there's this collection
and we have to see yeah what what to do
with it and if we if there have to be
owners found and doing this research now
with the committee yeah and you're a
you're a bit of an expert on this kind
of thing because I bet we saw the story
about them the Ludwig Museum in in in
Cologne they had to return a kokoschka
that's an interesting story have you
been involved in those kind of
restitution stories as well give us an
idea of sort of what the parameters are
yes because our collection has so many
words from modernism yes this is the
period it's a period we have hundred
twenty-eight works and where the which
was not clear totally clear what between
33 and 45 happened with it works and so
we had we are doing for 10 years already
provenance research and since four years
very intense with for research three or
four researchers and now we reduce it to
33 works and and and in two or three
cases especially we are doing a lot of
more research to find out what was going
on but and it is difficult because the
archives in Paris or London and they
often close or materialists destroyed
and it's very difficult to find out it's
quite a tortured position for you to be
in effectively sitting there being in
charcoal thing works of art that may it
may be baby may be proven that they are
stolen worked about the less it works
about stolen from Jewish
of course but we have one case where we
have questions from three sides you
can't and divided and three proud so you
have to do really intense I'm research
to find out who was the right owner
mm-hmm so it's very complex Toria given
that you've been doing work on
restitution and giving an awful lot of
thought to that and you're also an
expert for the classical modernism of
the 20th century people like power play
and candid skin all sorts of other
people try and answer the next question
for me which is and this is a another
level upwards now is that Germany
created so much wonderful art of this
period but Germany was also so hateful
of this art at one at the same time how
does that you know how do you explain
that hmm so mid 20s have been very
radical and German Expressionism on and
this new media film and early forms of
performance already and so very very
radical period but the society perhaps
was not made sure enough to so it was
something environment of the public it
was very mar republic yeah right not a
republic for it was a very special
situation on the one hand and many and
strong tradition from the 19th century
still and on the other hand with
avant-garde and yeah it's a long story
how it was possible and that in the
third i am the things good could be cut
up so from one here to another room or
such a cut and development just to go
back to the munich story that the
authorities there are now talking about
returning a large quantity possibly of
those works of art to mr. Gurlitt yeah
does that surprise you does that shock
you does that seem plausible we are
speaking about about 300 works and I
know it from the media as you so I have
known the collection before so we all
have been surprised by it and it has to
be it's always the question if you
ask the lawyers or if something like a
commission which are and deciding on a
more ethic ethical basis ecol tactics
basis and we have in germany these
limbaugh's commission it's a group of
people and there's one art historian and
they're coming from different fields of
society and they're deciding together on
this ethical basis and that's the
question it's more loyal question or is
it my and it's to complicate that i can
give you hear an answer to it we have to
weigh some other weeks and month but i
know that they just found a task force a
group of people who are only
concentrating on this case of college
and i think they will start in the next
days or weeks back it took a little bit
of time but it sir but they've got that
finally let's change the subject a
little bit him do you jog joke which we
dog a dog ah oh yes I not not true in
the traditional ways I i I'm my son in
seven years old yeah and he loves it to
jog and so I started with him oh wow
that's good do you go to the movies it's
it's a problem when you're working so
hard and have family so that's where I'm
doing things very good another good
cooker as I am coming from a feminist
traditional family so my mother my
grandmother and my aunt and before that
nobody could cook from the few minutes
what you call a family's tradition you
let you live on the River Rhine yeah
just dropped you go for walks along the
Rhine yes I've go ahead okay yeah I mean
I you'll find out in just a moment you
might be wondering why I'm asking all
these questions and you will find out
it's got something to do with detective
stories and just about it love you might
yeah and just about 40 kilometers down
the Rhine from Dusseldorf where Moran
lives is the city of Cologne it is the
first city in Germany with what I
suppose you might call a detective story
dispenser
we have that report on the show because
of you because of Mary Ann Ackerman
because because there's a rumor going
around that you're a big fan of
detective stories you know it is a
strange thing is that many art
historians love a crime novels I don't
know yeah it is I don't know why my just
a sec that's not very interesting yeah I
had explained why yeah uh-huh I like it
too I'm trying to fit this the other now
because we discovered earlier that the
the art world is still a male-dominated
world at least at the top level yeah
like so many areas of German life mmm i
was on the underground this morning yeah
coming into work thinking about you of
course and and there were two people
sitting opposite me both reading what
were quite obviously detective stories
one of them was an American detective
sorry one of them was a Scandinavian
very popular at the moment I've you
probably read Scandinavian they were
both women I wonder it a detective story
so a woman's think I don't think they
don't think so no and many writers are
also mail as oh no no no what wouldn't
wouldn't agree ok I know many of male
readers you just gave me an idea though
because it have you read the English
detective story writer Kate Atkinson no
I haven't read ah right I'm so good ok
tannic acid yeah and I'll tell you what
one of her stories is called because you
were just saying that you know people in
your business yeah ya like like
detective stories it's called behind the
scenes of the museum yes in ok it just
like crime normal what we are doing at
the moment with phone these always
stories with very true very true there's
one thing we must do before we get too
near to the end of the show we like to
ask our guests to bring along a prize a
treasured or an interesting possession
or an artifact you've brought this along
yeah explain to me what it is first of
all it is the cut out so it is a razor
blade you can see a razor blade out of
paper and it's it's in the color pink in
a very fluorescence color you see quite
small and in a Plexiglas box you're just
closed you can't open it okay now you're
give me some points here now
I'm going to try and interpret what I've
got in my hand yeah and you tell me
whether I'm interpreting it right now
there's a rule of them maybe this is
about irony because it's a razor blade
that is made of paper yeah maybe it's
about transparency because it's in a
little box that you can see into mm-hmm
but really they're not really maybe the
color pink is significant that's that
would agree it well you're in the color
mmm I mean you know think would you tell
me what look I've always the kind of
think about so um I can tell you what
yeah just told me it is an artwork it's
loll at work not not not big enough for
a big art market but it's an odd word
nice and transportable as well as many
of the best hard work so happy and so
the artist Simon parrot in front from
London he told me when if climb would
have born in our times yeah you would
have taken pink as his color instead of
the eve Klein blue legendary blue which
meant opening off the this guy and so
and and and he said pink is the color of
our times and of the color of the future
and I liked it so much because it's like
a symbol for what art can do so he's
cutting he's doing cuts so he can be
politically can be and yeah changed
something and but at the same time it's
a very aesthetic thing that's very nice
beautiful little bit larger and it's
sort of cut out so everybody can do it
yeah so it's it's a real simple
vegetable these days aren't they cut
outs now yeah yeah they've came back so
it's really a fashion no yeah that's
true okay I'm very very grateful indeed
for you bringing that along and I've
discovered now that not only are there
many shades of white but also that pink
is the color of our times it's time for
our quiz quick questions quick answers
abstract or figurative for you attract
ancient or modern modern oh no surprise
there clay or Kandinsky Kandinsky do you
want from painting consolation or
confrontation
art museums temples or playgrounds
nothing but no I would sit in between in
between my god okay grace up thank you
haha that's your lot with the eloquent
and entertaining mari on a command
telling us all about the secrets of
color there's more talking Germany
including my blog on our and and our
archived on our website if you've
enjoyed today's show as much as I have
come back next week until then bye-bye
and truce